Hello family. I'm Jill Moricone. We just
welcome you to 3BN Bible Q&A. I love
this today program because we take your
Bible questions and our Bible students
here answer those questions. This is a
time to get into the word of God to
study to show ourselves approved unto
God to learn what God's word has for us
and that practical implication we can
take it in as it were digest it and eat
it and learn and grow together. I want
to introduce to you my family on the set
with us here. And we have some joining
remotely, but they're still family and
they're your family as well. We have
Pastor Ryan Johnson here. Pastor Ryan,
so glad to have you here.
>> It's wonderful to be here. It's always
an honor to uh get into the word with
our extended family and our media
family.
>> Amen. That's right. And we have Pastor
James Rafferty. Thank you for the wide
shot. You can we can look at you right
across the table here even though you're
not here in person. Pastor James, so
glad to have you here.
>> Good to be here, Jill and Pastor Ryan.
Looking forward to today's program and
the questions and of course the answers
from the word of God.
>> Amen. It's so important. I love that.
want to tell you if you want to send in
your questions on an upcoming 3BN today
Bible Q&A program, we will answer them.
So if you want to send in your
questions, you can text them
618-2283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
You can email them. That's Bible
QA3ABN.tv.
Bible Q&A. That stands for questions
answers at 3ABN.tv.
Or you can go to Instagram. 3ABN has our
Instagram account. That's 3ABN_official.
And you can take a look and send in your
questions that way. So any way you send
them in, we would love to receive them.
You can let us know maybe where you're
from. We'd love to share that as well.
Before we go to the first question and
just jump into the program, we want to
go to the Lord in prayer. Pastor James,
would you pray for us here today?
>> Absolutely. Father in heaven, just want
to thank you for this opportunity to
lift our hearts to heaven. I want to
thank you for each viewer. Just ask that
you'll continue to work in their lives.
And if there are questions that pertain
to them, I pray the Holy Spirit would
give them the grace and the wisdom to
accept and to let those answers come as
a revelation from heaven, from your
word. I want to pray that you'll be with
each one of us, Father, as we share, as
we open the Bible, that you will teach
and instruct and lead. So we give you
this time. We give you our hearts in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> I love what you said, Pastor James,
there. That's just so powerful because
in that prayer because we want the truth
to come in and to change us and to
internalize it. Not just study and throw
it out over here, but to actually accept
it and internalize it because that's
what God does by the power of the Holy
Spirit as we talk about God changing us.
Let's go to Pastor Ryan's first question
here. This came in from Missy in
Tennessee via text.
>> Can you forgive someone after they die
and be truly forgiven by God?
>> Oh, thank you so much, Sister Missy.
That's a great question. In fact, the
issue of forgiveness is coming up a lot
lately because we are in a time when we
need to learn to forgive one another.
And before we get into this, I always
like to preface when we're talking about
forgiveness, Sister Jill, that we
understand there are some people that
have really, really, truly been hurt.
Yeah.
>> And when we are urged to forgive, we are
in no way saying that we are
discrediting the pain that one has been
through. But the question is, can we
forgive someone after they have died?
And will Christ recognize our change of
heart having forgiven them? And the
short answer to that is yes. Yes, we
certainly can. You know, I remember when
I was um in pastoral work, we did a
funeral and at the end of the funeral,
the pastors are standing there um right
in front of the the casket and the
daughter of the woman who's being buried
walks by with a flower and just throws
the flower down in there and says, "Bye,
Mom. I will never forget that." But what
we thought and prayed after that was the
Lord can and will work on that young
lady's heart because clearly there were
some things to forgive.
>> So I'll tell you what, let's lighten
this up a bit and and create an example
after which we can see why Christ must
allow us to forgive others even if those
people have died. So imagine someone
does something that has hurt you. Let's
just let's make this light. Let's say
they deliberately spilled something on
your favorite chair on purpose and
laughed at you and you say, you know, I
will never forgive you for that. And
they laughing just storm out of your
apartment or wherever. They go
downstairs and unfortunately while
they're waiting on the bus, I don't
know, a piano falls down and and they
die right there and you had not had an
opportunity to forgive them. Is it gone?
>> Can you never forgive them? Well, let's
look at what this means. Remember,
forgiveness is something that Christ
gives us the urge to do. This is a
Christlike quality, forgiveness. So to
say that because they have died, you
cannot forgive is the same as saying
that though they've died, Christ cannot
change you. Oh, that's not true.
>> That's true.
>> That's the same as saying that because
you had not had a chance to forgive them
before they died, you have committed a
sin that cannot be forgiven. And that's
not biblical. So just by that little
playful logic we see that yes it is
possible for Christ to work on us even
though the person whom we need to
forgive has died. Now the Bible clearly
says that the living know that they
shall die. The dead do not know know not
anything. So even if you must forgive a
person after they have died,
reconciliation with that person, hey
look at this, can occur in the kingdom.
Can you imagine that? that a person did
you wrong. They went out, found the
Lord, they fell asleep in Jesus before
you had a chance to forgive them. You
forgive them. The Lord works on your
heart. You forgive them. You all make it
to the kingdom. And when you see them at
the welcome table, they say, "Oh, my
friend, I'm so sorry." And you say, "My
friend, I had forgiven you by Christ
Jesus." And you hug it out. Now, I'd
like to finish this by getting a little
scriptural because we've been talking
hypothetically. Let's see what the word
of God says in Matthew chapter 6:14.
Look what Jesus says, have all this red
writing here. It says, "For if ye, you,
my brother or sister, forgive men their
trespasses." Now, where it says men
there in the Greek, it means people, men
and women, your heavenly father will
also forgive you. And what I want you to
notice here, just by this verse, is that
the heart of forgiveness is between you
and God. You see that? if you forgive
your heavenly father. So forgiveness is
between you and God. Reconciliation and
forgiveness is you and your brother or
sister and that can occur in the
kingdom.
>> Amen. Praise the Lord. Thank you so
much, Pastor Ryan. That gives a lot of
hope, doesn't it? Praise the Lord. We're
going to stay on the concept of
forgiveness and come to Pastor James.
Now, this is forgiveness, but a a little
different angle here. This came in via
text from Texas. The New Testament
teaches forgiveness. Does this mean that
God is no longer for the death penalty?
>> Seriously,
>> that is a great question. Thank you for
that question from Texas. You know, the
Old Testament teaches forgiveness also.
Uh the Old Testament sanctuary service
was all about forgiveness and the
sacrifices of the animals pointed
forward to the ultimate sacrifice of the
lamb. You know, David was forgiven for
his adultery with Bashibba and for his
murdering of Uriah, her husband. Noah
was forgiven for getting drunk. Abraham
was forgiven for lying about his wife
twice.
>> And Jacob was forgiven for deceiving his
father. Joseph and forgave his brothers.
Samson was forgiven. The list goes on
and on and on. So, the Old Testament
also is filled with this emphasis of
forgiveness and the gospel. Mhm.
>> Now, [clears throat] while the New
Testament does focus on forgiveness, it
also includes stories like Ananas and
Safh who actually received the death
penalty for sinning against the Holy
Spirit. And uh and this was during the
apostolic church period, right? Acts
chapter 5 1-12, the Holy Spirit had been
poured out. And yet Ananas and Safh had
uh deceived or tried to deceive the
church leaders and ultimately uh God
brought justice to them right away. The
death penalty to them right away. So we
see the death penalty in the New
Testament. Now ultimately the New
Testament emphasis is based on these Old
Testament types, right? That all pointed
to Christ. So we see in the Old
Testament that God ruled basically
directly, you know, a theocracy so he
could carry out justice and mercy which
were blended. But justice did not wait
long since God was able to know the
hearts and therefore make accurate
determinations about people. Now in the
New Testament uh the authority has been
delegated to earthly governments to
exercise judgment under God which
includes the death penalty. We can see
this in Romans chapter 13 1-5. So let's
just take a look at these verses. I
think they're really good verses for us
to consider. Romans 13 1-5. It says
here, "Let every soul be subject unto
the higher powers. For there is no power
but God. The powers that are that be
that are are ordained of God. Verse two,
whosoever therefore resists the power
resists the ordinance of God. And they
that resist shall receive to themselves
damnation. Verse three, for rulers are
not a terror to good works, but to the
evil. Wilt thou then not be afraid of
the power? Do that which is good, and
thou shalt have praise of the same. For
he, the earthly government, is a
minister of God to thee for good. But if
thou do e Oh, excuse me. But yeah, but
if thou do evil, if thou do that which
is evil, be afraid, for he bears not the
sword in vain. For he is a minister of
God, a revenger to execute wrath upon
him that doeth evil. Wherefore, verse 5,
you must needs be subject not only for
wrath, but also for conscience sake. So
here Romans chapter 13 is clearly
telling us that earthly governments are
to administer justice. And sometimes
those earthly governments are liable to
heir in the exercise of justice. And
this is a major factor to be considered
in the administration of the death
penalty. God doesn't heir and he will
carry out the ultimate death penalty for
all evil done on planet earth. And we we
see that in the context of revelation
especially chapter 20. But until then,
earthly governments have God's authority
to execute the death penalty when
evidence is clear and the evil warrants
such actions. And that's clearly
demonstrated here in Romans chapter 13.
But we also see that clearly
demonstrated even in the apostolic
church. So we finite man are to be
subject to the governments and the
powers that be the laws that be in in uh
submission to in a sense submission to
God who's ordained these powers to be
and part of those laws will include the
death penalty when it's uh applicable
and important to be applied to those who
have transgressed or who done evil in
transgression of those those earthly
laws.
>> Thank you so much Pastor James. That's
really good. I love the nuance and the
difference between God as the perfect
lawgiver and as humanity carries out
with our weaknesses that with our flaws
that perfect law. Yeah. Very good. Thank
you, pastor. Pastor Ryan, we're coming
back to you. This is still kind of on
the concept of forgiveness or repentance
or nonrepentance. Let's talk about that.
We're going to talk about Judas.
>> This came from Harvey. He lives in
Canada and he sent the question in via
email.
Jesus knew Judas would betray him at the
last supper. Judas handed him over for
30 pieces of silver, but later felt
remorse and threw the money back to the
religious leaders before taking his own
life.
>> So, the question is, will Judas be saved
and raised in the first resurrection?
>> Oh, wow. Now, that is a great question.
Um, in fact, before we get into it, I
would like to say that my personal
policy is even with people that it seems
absolutely sure that they're going to uh
heaven or they will be lost, I try to
leave that judgment [laughter]
to the Lord and not cast my opinion. But
as far as Judas is concerned, the Bible
is absolutely clear. Judas is a
fascinating study, a sadly fascinating
study because he walked and talked with
Jesus. I know.
>> And yet, as we will see, he was lost.
Now, I've had some people come to me and
say, "How can I make it if Judas was
lost and he walked and talked with
Jesus?" It is indeed possible that we
can be in the church sitting in the pew
and yet not have a relationship with
Jesus Christ. But don't be discouraged.
Jesus saved 11. Jesus could have and
would have saved Judas if Judas was
willing. In fact, let's go ahead and
have a look at it. As the brother has
already shown in the question, Judas had
what he thought was a better idea of the
kind of king that Jesus would be. And so
he betrayed Jesus. And we have shown in
various texts and other things that
Judas thought he would force Jesus to be
the kind of leader, the earthly leader
that he thought. He betrayed Jesus for
30 pieces of silver, make it
transactional, also have a little money
so he can go do some stuff, have a
survival right there. Judas was a
survivor. And look what it says in
Matthew chapter 27. I'm going to read
verse 3 to 5. It says, "Then Judas,
which had betrayed Jesus, when he saw
that Jesus was condemned, that Jesus
wouldn't flex and save himself. He
repented himself and brought again the
30 pieces of silver to the chief priests
and elders, saying, I have sinned."
That's a confession. And that I have
betrayed the innocent blood. And they
said, "What is that to us? See thou to
that." and he cast down the pieces of
silver in the temple, departed and went
and hanged himself. It is clear right
here that Judas felt bad. In fact, the
word that is used here is that he
repented. Now, I would like to show you
an interesting text. This is 2
Corinthians chapter 7 and I'm going to
read verse 9. It says, is Paul talking?
Now I rejoice not that ye were made
sorry. Oo, but that ye sorrowed to
repentance, for ye were made sorry after
a godly manner, that ye might receive
damage by us nothing. For godly sorrow
workketh repentance to salvation, not to
be repented of, but the sorrow of the
world workketh death. Now, I want to
show you another scripture. This is
Matthew chapter 3. So I can get there in
time. And I'm going to read verse two.
Look what Jesus has to say. Matthew
chapter 3 and verse two, the Bible says,
"And saying, this is John the Baptist,
repent ye, for the kingdom of heaven is
at hand." So we see this word repent
showing up twice. It was used in Judas
with talking about Judas. But we see it
twice. We see it there in in Paul
speaking and we see it there in Matthew.
And they both show up as repent in the
translation. But would you be interested
to know that the Greek words are
different? Yeah.
>> And because they're different, my Greek
pronunciation is horrible. I'm just
going to try my best. When it talks
about the repentance that leads to a
change of heart, Matthew 3, that word is
metano
and it means to repent, to change the
heart, to turn. But the repentance that
Judas experienced, that word is metami.
And that means he felt sorry, which
means Judas felt bad, but Judas did not
feel the urge for change.
>> That's powerful stuff.
>> And so when he's there and he's throwing
down the 30 pieces of silver, it is the
worldly sorrow that Paul talks about
that Judas is experiencing. And you may
be saying, "Wait a minute, preacher. Can
God not work with that? Do we not in our
Christian journey often begin with
worldly sorrow? And the answer is yes.
>> Many a time a person has found him or
herself in prison and it begins with
that worldly sorrow. Oh, I messed up.
[clears throat] The Lord can work with
that. But Judas did not give Jesus an
opportunity to change his heart. His
mistake was not taking it to the master
>> and he hanged himself and we are to
understand that he will not be in the
first resurrection. Now you can read
about the first resurrection I believe
in Revelation 20:6. This is the holy one
when those who are raised will go into
the kingdom. But Judas being lost will
be raised in the second resurrection.
And that's not the one we want anything
to do with. I want to close talking a
bit about suicide.
If this is something you're
contemplating, listen, Jesus loves you.
>> There is help.
>> And for the rest of us, let us not be
the kind of people that say, "Don't
commit suicide. You're going to hell."
That is not the kind of talk.
>> But let us take it to the master. God be
with you. I have to say it on the heels
of that. You be encouraged, brother.
>> Be encouraged, sister. Amen.
>> Amen. Thank you so much, Pastor Ryan.
Very biblical, but hope as well for us.
So, praise the Lord for that. As we
think about that concept of repentance,
non-repentance, salvation, we're going
to Pastor James and this verse has to do
with salvation too of the Gentiles. Um,
this came from Wilson from Grenada, and
they sent it in via email. My question
centers on Romans 11:es [clears throat]
25 and 26. These verses seem to suggest
that God has partially blinded Israel to
allow time for the Gentile salvation and
that later all Israel will be saved. How
should we understand this passage in
Romans and the idea that all Israel will
be saved?
>> That is a great question. Thank you
Wilson from Grenada. really appreciated,
Pastor Ryan, what you shared that as uh
Sister Yvon Shelton would say that was
rich. Some very valuable insights there
and I love the idea that a prisoner,
someone who's death row maybe and or
just in prison, you know, reconsidering
their actions,
>> give God time to work. Judas didn't give
God time to work. So, I love that that
whole that's just gives me a whole new
insight into that uh into that truth.
>> So, Romans 11:25 and 26, let's just read
those verses. uh here Romans 11:25 and
26. For I would not, brethren, that ye
should be ignorant of this mystery, lest
you should be wise in your own conceits
that blindness in part is happened to
Israel
until the fullness of the Gentiles be
come in.
>> And so all Israel shall be saved as as
it is written, there shall come out out
of Zion a deliverer and shall turn away
ungodliness from Jacob. All Israel shall
be saved. And of course, that's the
phrase that many of our evangelical
brothers and sisters focus on when they
think about all of this focus on God's
people in the Middle East and Israel in
the Middle East. But is that really in
harmony with the context of what Paul is
saying in Romans chap 11? See, when we
read the context of the book of Romans
carefully and prayerfully, this chapter
fits perfectly with Paul's overarching
understanding that is found in all his
writings. For example, in Romans chapter
2 28 and 29, Paul says, "He is not a Jew
which is one outwardly, neither is that
circumcision which is outward in the
flesh, but he is a Jew which is one
inwardly, and circumcision is that of
the heart in the spirit, and not of the
letter, whose praise is not of men, but
of God." So this inward circumcision,
this inward Jewishness so to speak,
Galatians chapter 3 beginning with verse
16 and looking at verses 26- 29 says
this. Now to Abraham and to his seed
were the promises made. He saith not to
seeds as of many, but as of one and to
thy seed which is Christ. So the seed
that the promises of Abraham were made
to is Jesus. It's not to many. It's not
to the Jewish nation as a nation, but
it's to the promised one, that is Jesus
Christ, who was the culmination, if you
will, the fruition, the fulfillment of
all the promises that were given to
Israel of old. He goes on to say this,
"But ye are all children of God by faith
in Jesus Christ." So now he's coming to
his point in verse 26. We're the
children of God by faith in Jesus.
>> For as many of you as have been baptized
into Christ, Christ have put on Christ.
Now when you do this, there is neither
Jew nor Greek. That's right. There is
neither bond nor free. There's neither
male nor female. You're all one in
Christ Jesus. And if you be be in
Christ, you are Abraham's seed and heirs
according to the promise. So all those
promises that we have in the Old
Testament, all those promises that
pointed toward Israel that we're saying
apply to Israel actually apply to
Abraham's seed and that is Christ. And
those who are in Christ, they are
actually the children of Abraham. So
Paul understood that while God was using
him as a minister to the Gentiles, God
was still and God still loved and longed
for as many Jews or of those of Israel
as possible to be saved. And Paul
recognized that not all would be saved,
but that he had a remnant. God had a
remnant who would accept Christ as
Messiah when they understood the Old
Testament more clearly. Now, with this
in mind, Paul clarifies what it means by
saying that all Israel shall be saved.
Here it is. Uh Romans 11:1 I say then
has God cast away his people? God forbid
for I also am an Israelite of the seed
of Abraham of the tribe of Benjamin. God
has not cast away his people which he
forneew. And then in verse six of
chapter 9, verses 6 through8 of chapter
9, not as though the word of God has
taken none effect. For they are not all
Israel, which are of Israel, neither
because they are the seed of Abraham are
they the children. But in Isaac shall
thy seed be called. That is, they which
are the children of the flesh. These are
not the children of God, but the
children of the promise are counted for
the seed. So we could actually summarize
Romans 11 2-6 in this way. Elijah says,
"All Israel has apostaside and I'm the
only one left." And God says, "No, I
have 7,000. I have a remnant. I have
those that are still true, true Israel,
and they are going to be saved. So when
we look at Paul's overarching theme in
Romans, Romans 2, Romans 9, Romans 11,
when he says that all Israel is going to
be saved, he's talking about how Israel
is not necessarily outward, but inward.
And God has his people among the
Israelites, but God all has also has his
people among the Gentiles, and he's
going to save all of them. If we have
more time, we could touch on this a
little bit more, but we'll close right
there and we'll just say that God's
purpose is to save Israel, whether they
be in the gent among the Gentiles or whe
they be among the Israelites, those who
truly are in Christ and receive the
promises that were given to Abraham.
>> I love that, Pastor James. Thank you so
much. That's spiritual Israel that we
can be in Christ. That's beautiful.
>> Is hope, too.
>> It is hope. Praise the Lord. Want to let
you know if you want to send in your
Bible questions for an upcoming Bible
Q&A program, you can email them bible
qa3abn.tv.
You can text them 6182283975.
You can send them in via Instagram at
3ABN official. So any of those ways,
send in your questions. We'd love to
answer them on an upcoming Bible QA
program. So, let's go to Pastor Ryan
here going to another verse in the
Bible. This one's in Jude.
>> Um, this came in from Paul via email.
How should we interpret Jude 1:24-2
in the King James version?
>> Oh, I'm so glad you asked that question.
This is one of my favorite text, man. I
was 19 years old, 18 years old, and um
my birthday's in February. It was the
new year and I went to church with my
older brother and we were sitting there
and the preacher preached this text
right here right on the precipice of the
brand new year and it has stuck with me
all these years. Let's read it. It says
in Jude 1, there's only one chapter
there. Verse 24, now unto him that is
able to keep you from falling and to
present you faultless before the
presence of his glory with exceeding
joy. To the only wise God, our savior be
glory. Have mercy. And majesty,
dominion, and power both now and
forever. Amen. I'm gonna do my best not
to preach while we go through this here.
>> You can preach.
>> No, I can do that. All right. Here we
go. This is a perfect doxology and
benediction. And if we had time, we kind
of go into what that means. But we're at
the end of a very short book here. In
fact, in order to really appreciate
what's going on, let's just let's set up
what's happening. So, as we said, the
book of Jude is actually an epistle. It
is a letter, and it's called a general
epistle. It's to everyone. And I'll show
you why. Unlike some of the other
epistles where it says, you know, this
is to the church here or there. It says
in Jude 1, uh, verse one, Jude, the
servant of Jesus Christ and brother of
James to them, and here's who it, too.
To all them that are sanctified by God
the Father and preserved in Jesus Christ
and called. Well, that's us. Well,
that's you, Sister Jill. That is you,
Pastor Rafferty. It is to all of us.
Now, when Jude begins to talk, he warns
us about a problem that he sees. And we
still have it today. There are false
teachers creeping into the church. We
can read about it in verse four. It
says, "For there are certain men, we're
in Jude 1, by the way. There are certain
men crept in unawares who were before of
old ordained to this condemnation,
ungodly men turning the grace of our God
into lasciviousness and denying the only
Lord Jesus and our Lord Jesus Christ. It
is clear right there that that Jude has
got a concern.
>> There is false doctrine coming in. But
when we look at verses 20 to 23, we see
that he tells us to be vigilant. He says
in verse 20, "But ye, beloved, building
up yourselves on your most holy faith,
pray in the Holy Ghost." And he goes on,
but by the time verse 24 comes along, we
get a shift. See, early on, we were
talking about the frailty of humanity,
the tendency of humans to be deceived
and to fall away. But when 24 comes
along, we shift to God's ability to keep
us from messing up. Have mercy. So,
let's go ahead and have a look at it. It
says now unto him that is able to keep
you from falling. That word able dinai
means has the power, has the capability.
Then it goes on to keep you from
falling. You think about that. We often
think about forgiveness and forgiveness
is wonderful. Praise his name. But he
also promises victory. Look what it says
in 1 Corinthians chapter 10:13. It says,
"There hath no temptation taken you, but
such as is common to man, but God is
faithful, who will not suffer you to be
tempted. Above that ye are able, but
will with the temptation also make a way
to escape."
>> Here the picture is painted that you can
be tempted and not fall because the Lord
will hold you up. And then it goes on to
say back in Jude that one day the Lord
can present you faultless. Think about
how messed up we are. And think about
the power of Jesus Christ and his blood
and what he's done for us. That one day
you can stand before his presence with
exceeding joy, completely faultless,
spotless, with a mountain fresh scent.
Can you imagine that, friends? That is
the change that Jesus Christ promises.
And then it says before his presence,
you can read in Exodus how we with our
sinful selves cannot currently stand in
the absolute presence of Jesus Christ.
We'd be consumed, but one day we will be
changed. Do you see the promise here?
And then the benediction hits. To the
only wise God, our savior be glory,
majesty, dominion, and power both now
and forever. Amen. And the promise is,
my friend, that God will not only
forgive you, but he will give you the
victory such that you will not fall by
his power, present you faultless, and
you will live with him for eternity.
That wasn't too much preaching. I
managed a little bit.
>> I love that. Praise the Lord. We're
having church. I love the fact he frees
us the penalty of sin and he gives us
power and victory over sin. Praise the
Lord for that. Pastor James, we're
coming to you here. This one is a text
that's often misunderstood or
misinterpreted. Um, this came in from
Zadei from Connecticut. Sent it in via
email. Can you explain Ephesians 1 verse
5? He predestined us for adoption to
sunship through Jesus Christ.
>> Amen. That's a great uh question.
Predestination is a big word. It simply
means to decide ahead of time and the
Bible is quite clear on the subject of
predestination. First, it teaches that
Christ was actually predestined uh to be
our savior to come to our rescue. He is
forained uh as the lamb of God slain
from the foundation of the world. one of
Shelley Quinn's favorite Bible texts in
Revelation 13 and:8. We also see that in
1 Peter chapter 1:18 and 19. But
secondly, God's word teaches
predestination as it applies to the
subjects of this great love. In other
words, God has predestined us for
eternal salvation. Now, the context of
this is found in Ephesians chapter 1.
So, let's look at Ephesians 1:es 3-5. It
says, "Blessed be God, the father of our
Lord Jesus Christ, who has blessed us
with all spiritual blessings in heavenly
places according verse four, as he hath
chosen us in him before the foundation
of the world." So there you see that
same phrase that we just saw applied to
Christ, now it's being applied to us.
Before the foundation of the world, he
has chosen us that we should be holy and
without blame before him in love. Verse
5 is kind of reiterating the same point.
having predestinated us unto the
adoption of children by Jesus Christ to
himself according to the good pleasure
of his will. So who was chosen to be
without blame before him? Who was chosen
before the foundation of the world to be
redeemed from sin? Who was predestined
to be adopted from the family of Satan
once we have fallen to the family of
God? Who has Jesus Christ died for?
Yeah.
>> Who should be eternally saved according
to the gospel of the good pleasure of
God's will? Who is the us? And the
answer from the Bible is well, let's
look at second Peter chapter 3 and verse
9. The Lord is not slack concerning his
promises. Some men count slack
slackness, but is longsuffering to us
would, not willing that any should
perish, but that all should come to
repentance. That's the first Bible verse
I ever preached. And I wasn't really
preaching it. I just become a Christian,
an Adventist, and they asked me to get
up front in church and give my
testimony. And so I read second Peter
3:9. And I said, "God is so
longsuffering. He's waited for me to be
saved. He's waited for me to come back
to him."
>> Another verse, 1 Timothy 2:4, tells us
that God's will is that all men would be
saved and come to a knowledge of the
truth. So Jesus Christ died for all
mankind, not just for a few proof, a few
pre-selected ones, right? Right? The
Bible's so clear on this. John 3:16 does
not say God so loved Christians or God
so loved Baptists or God so loved
Adventists or God so loved Catholics. It
says God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son that whosoever
believes in him should not perish but
have everlasting life. Now you may hear
the argument well you know Christ uh in
his great wisdom his fornowledge God
knew who would be saved and who would be
lost right? And so that's why his blood
only applies to those who he decided to
save. Well, Christ knew that Judas would
betray him, but he still washed his
feet. Uh, he knew that only one leper
would come back to give him thanks, but
he still cleansed all 10. Uh, he knew
that most of the Jews and Romans who
were crucifying him would never accept
him, but he still asked God to forgive
them. You know, the Bible says that
Jesus Christ suffered and died for all
mankind. In Hebrews chapter 2:9 it says,
"But we see Jesus who was made a little
lower than the angels for the suffering
of death, crowned with glory and honor
that he by the grace of God should test
taste death for everyone." For everyone.
Jesus was predestined to die for the
sins of every man, woman, and child that
has ever lived or ever will live. The
Lord laid on him the iniquity Isaiah
53:6 of us all. That's right. So God
gave his son for all of us for the world
for whoever whosoever might believe and
that is a wonderful powerful thought. So
according to the Bible, God has
predestined us to be saved. And this
predestination does not come according
to our works, but according to his
grace. Second Timothy chapter 2 1-8
tells us. 2 Timothy chapter 1 1 or 8-10
tells us that predestination comes to
those for whom Christ has died. And
since Christ died for all humanity, all
humanity has been predestined to
salvation. And predestination is for
those of whom it is God's will to save.
And since God is willing that none be
lost, it's for everyone. Right? Those
who perish will perish because they
refuse to be adopted as children of God
through Jesus Christ. But the gifts and
the calling of God are without
repentance. The redemption ransom of
Christ has freely been given for those
who will spurn the gift and choose not
to repent, they will be lost. But in
spite of its rejection, God's grace is
given. And where sin abounded, grace did
much more abound. That's what we're told
in Romans chapter 5 and verse 20. So we
need to remember that the sacrifice of
Christ was for all transgression, for
all sin because he came and seek to seek
and save those who are lost. And Satan
knows this. He knows this. So he is
trying to to to rest out of the hand of
Christ every soul he can possibly
influence. Yet there's no reason except
for our own refusal of the gift why all
men cannot and should not be saved.
Brian, you're inspiring me here. I was
just going to keep on preaching, but I'm
way out of time.
We're having church here. I love that.
God loves us. God wants to save us. God
wants to crush the serpent's head. And
our next question is about that. Pastor
Ryan, this is from Tony from Canada.
When did Jesus crush the devil's head?
Was it at his birth standing up to him
while fasting for 40 days using the
scriptures to him resurrection morning
or at his coming?
>> Oh, thank you. That's an excellent
question, Tony. because it was promised
that Christ would crush the head of the
serpent. Let's get right into it. Before
we go to where that promise is located,
let's get some some identifying uh
terminology here. I'm going to start in
Revelation 12. And it says in verse 9,
"And the great dragon
was cast out, that old serpent," there
it is. Who's the serpent called the
devil and Satan which deceiveth the
whole world? He was cast out into the
earth and his angels were cast out with
him. Right here we see who the serpent
is. The serpent is Satan. So when we go
to this next prophecy, we know who it is
that is being spoken to. And so now
let's go right over to Genesis chapter 3
and we are going to read what happens to
be the first promise recorded in the
Bible of the redeemer. Now we are told
in Revelation that Christ was slain from
the foundation of the world. The plan of
redemption has been around for a long
long time. But here we get the promise.
This is immediately after um Adam and
Eve, man and woman, had fallen. And they
are there in the garden freshly fallen.
Let's begin in verse 11. And he said,
"Who told you you were naked? Have you
eaten of the tree whereof I commanded
thee that thou shouldest not eat?" And
the man said, "The woman whom you gavest
to me to be with me, she gave of me of
the tree, and I did eat." Verse 13. And
the Lord God said to the woman, "What is
this that thou hast done?" And the woman
said, "The serpent beguiled me, and I
did eat." And the Lord God said to the
serpent, here it is, "Because thou has
done this, thou art cursed above all
cattle, and above every beast of the
field, upon thy belly shalt thou go, and
dust shalt thou eat all the days of thy
life." And here it is the promise, "And
I will put enmity," that word in
between. Enmity means hatred, between
thee and the woman. I found it
interesting that that word woman also
could mean a wife that has fallen from
grace. Christ restores. Have mercy. I
will put hatred between you and the
woman and between thy seed and her seed.
And here's the promise. It shall bruise
thy head. He's talking to the serpent
will crush thy head, but thou shalt
bruise his heel. Here the redeemer is
promised because it says it shall bruise
thy head and thou shalt bruise his heel.
And also the promise is coming that the
head of the serpent will be crushed. And
when exactly did that take place? In the
interest of time, we're going to go
right over to Hebrews chapter 2. And I'm
going to read I can get there
>> verses 14 and 15. Look what the Bible
says in Hebrews 2 14 and 15. The
question is, when was the serpent's head
crushed? It says, "For as much then as
the children are partakers of the flesh
of flesh and blood, he also himself
likewise took part of the same," talking
about Christ, "that through death he
might destroy him that had the power of
death, that is the devil." And we are
told right here in this scripture that
it was at Christ's crucifixion that the
head of the serpent was crushed right
there. Well, when he was born,
>> the serpent was thwarted because they
tried to take Jesus out. In the
wilderness, the serpent was defeated by
the power of the word of God. On the
cross, the head of the serpent was
crushed, but at the second coming, the
serpent shall be destroyed. Now, you're
like, "What's the difference?" Well, you
got to remember that this is an
ideological war. You ever hear how
sometimes terrorists are in are in cells
and if you just destroy one cell,
another one will pop up. You got to
crush the head. You have to kill the
ideology. The ideology of sin was
completely destroyed at the cross right
there.
>> That is when it happened. But when
Christ comes again, the serpent will be
cast into the fire. And that's when he
will be destroyed. But it was at the
cross. At the cross where I first saw
the light,
that is where the head of the serpent
was crushed. Let's just take a minute, a
second, and say, "Thank you, Jesus, for
crushing the head of the serpent."
>> Amen. I love that, Pastor Ryan. Thank
you so much. And you met Satan is
eventually destroyed and the lake of
fire and destroyed forever at Jesus
third coming.
>> Oh, yes. After the millennium. Good
catch, sister.
>> Perfect. Let's go to Pastor James here.
This is We talked quite a bit about
Satan. The last question. This is about
evil angels. This came from Carol in
Washington via email. If second Peter
says, "Evil angels are bound in chains
of darkness, how can Ephesians say we're
fighting against spiritual forces? Are
evil angels free or bound?"
>> Great question, Carol from Washington.
Thank you so much. That's, you know,
that makes a lot of sense. You know, in
1 Peter 5:8, the Bible says, "Be sober,
be vigilant, because your adversary, the
devil, as a roaring lion, walks about
seeking who he may devour." So, we know
that Satan isn't bound. What about his
angels? In 2 Corinthians 11 13-15,
we're told that Satan has ministers, his
angels, the devils uh uh come in the
guise of ministers of righteousness. It
says here, "For such are false apostles,
deceitful workers, transforming
themselves into apostles of Christ, for
no marvel. For Satan himself is
transformed into an angel of light. And
therefore, it is no great thing." Verse
15, if his ministers also be transformed
as the ministers of righteousness, whose
end shall be according to their works.
So, we know that they're not bound
completely. So, then the question you
asked is what about 2 Peter 2:4 and Jude
uh verse 6 that basically describes
fallen angels in chains of darkness.
Now, this is figurative language. Fallen
angels are not in literal chains. It
represents their being bound in
darkness, their inability to see the
light of God's love and be saved. It's
not a literal chain because we know
demons cannot be held by literal chain
since they are spiritual beings. In
fact,
>> the story in Mark, Mark 5 talks about
the those who are demonpossessed not
being able to be bound by chains. In
Mark chapter 5, it talks about in verse
one how Jesus came over to the other
side of the sea in the country of the
ghetines. And when he was come out of
the ship immediately, verse two says,
there met him of out of the tombs, a man
with an unclean spirit or a devil
possessed man. And in verse three, who
had his in his his dwellings among the
tombs, and no man could bind him not
with chains. Verse four, because he had
been bound before with feathers and
chains, and the chains have been plucked
us under, and the feathers broken in
pieces, neither could any man tame him.
So we see here that literal chains can't
bind demons. They can't bind the devil.
So what we're talking about here is a
spiritual darkness. And of course verse
uh 12 reminds us of Mark chapter 5 that
we're talking about devils here. The
unclean spirits. We're talking about
devils. And Jesus releases that man from
the bondage of devils, the control of
devils, of evil spirits that he is in.
So the Bible actually tells us that
devils can possess people. So they must
not be bound up in literal chains. They
must be bound in chains of darkness. In
fact, in Revelation chapter 16,
Revelation, my favorite book, and and
Pastor Ryan second favorite book, right,
Ryan? In Revelation chapter 16, I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs come
out of the mouth of the dragon, out of
the mouth of the beast, out of the mouth
of the false prophet. They are the
spirits of devils working miracles, and
they're going forth
>> to the kings of the earth and to the
whole world to gather them to the great
day, the great battle of that great day
of God Almighty. So definitely they're
not literally chained up. And so you're
right about Ephesians chapter 6. We're
involved in a spiritual warfare, Carol.
And in that spiritual warfare, we're
fighting against spiritual entities.
Angels are free to roam and to tempt
people as noted in in the context of the
story of ma of Mark 5. But Jesus is
greater than fallen angels. He cast that
devil. He cast those demons out of that
devil possessed man. He is able to
deliver us from all of the spiritual
darkness and our temptations and to
present us as Ryan said earlier, Pastor
Ryan said earlier, faultless before the
throne of God without spot or wrinkle or
any such thing. Praise God.
>> Amen. That's powerful. I love that. Last
question for you, Pastor Ryan. This came
from Elizabeth from Oregon. She sent it
in via text. When someone joins the
church and says the Holy Spirit told
them a recently deceased relative is in
heaven. Okay.
>> Are we supposed to gently share
scripture showing that the dead sleep
and will not enter heaven until Jesus
returns?
>> Oh wow, that is a great question because
this is really a question about how to
deal with people you know when they are
in error. And for those of you all who
are saying how do you know they are in
error? We're going to look at the
scripture and see. So what should you do
if someone say is recently grieving and
they say the Holy Spirit told them that
their recently deceased loved one is in
heaven? Well, the Holy Spirit telling
them. I want to leave that part aside
right now and let's just see what the
Bible says we should do. Well, it says
in Ephesians chapter 4, I'm going to
read verse 14 and 15. It says that we
henceforth be no more children tossed to
and fro and carried about with every
wind of doctrine
>> by the slight of men and cunning
craftiness whereby they lie and wait to
deceive. And here it is. But speaking
the truth in love.
>> Yeah.
>> May grow up into him in all things which
is the head even Christ. Remember when
the Lord introduced truth to us?
>> We must speak the truth. So that's what
the Bible said. But we must speak it in
love. You know what that means? Because
it says God is love. We have to speak
the truth in a godly fashion. Do you
know what that means? That means before
we tell someone else to straighten up,
we got to be prayed up. So let us
continue in prayer always so that when
the opportunity to give the truth comes
forth, we will do so in a godly fashion.
Christ never failed to speak the truth
and neither should we. But we must do so
in love. So what is the truth? Let's go
ahead and have a look at it. I'm going
to turn to Ecclesiastes chapter 9. And
here's what the Bible says in verse 5.
The truth is clear. It is plain. And
here it is, friends. Hopefully, I'm
speaking it in love, Sister Jill. For
the living know that they shall die.
>> But the dead know not anything, nothing.
Neither have they anymore a reward, for
the memory of them is forgotten. So in
this specific case where someone told
someone else that they were impressed
that their relative who had died was in
heaven, the Bible speaks expressly
against that. The dead do not know
anything. The dead do not know anything.
They are sleeping. They are waiting on
one resurrection or another. And you may
think that's not a big deal. Just let
them have that. And you know, I was
studying recently, you remember we were
talking about this, Pastor Rafferty, the
history of the Ouija board. And I don't
want to get all into that, but do you
know that that entire enterprise took
off
>> because of the belief that the deceased
could hear what was being said?
>> An entire movement known as spiritualism
where people were unknowingly many of
them and unwittingly talking to demons
and thinking they were talking to their
deceased. That is why the Bible says it
is clear. You need to know
>> that the dead are not aware. That's why
it's a big deal. We should take our
petitions to the Lord. Pray only to the
Lord. So it is serious business. But if
you must, in this specific instance,
something that we call the state, the
condition, what is going on with the
dead, if you must tell someone, no, your
loved one is not in heaven. My personal
advice is you don't leave them without
hope. Paul says them that have no hope.
You don't walk away. You don't in effigy
just remove their grandmother from glory
and say she's sleeping. Give them hope.
The Bible gives us hope. 1 Thessalonians
chapter 4 16-18. Some of my favorite
words right there. The Lord himself
shall descend from heaven with a shout.
will call to your grandmother, your
mother, your daughter, your son,
whomever it is that is sleeping, and
they will rise first, and we which are
alive and remain shall be caught up
together with them in the clouds to meet
the Lord in the air. Do you feel that
hope? I feel it every time I say it. You
can impart that hope. In fact, that
scripture ends with the promise that
every time we recite the hope, we get
comfort.
>> Amen. I praise the Lord for that. The
truth in his word. Pastor James, last
question from Ron via email. For those
who die without Christ, do they face
hell immediately at his coming or only
after the thousand-year period?
>> Good question, Ron. Thank you so much
for that. The ultimate punishment for
sin is after the 1,000 years. Uh during
which those who are not in Christ are
judged. So that's during the thousand
years, sentenced during the thousand
years according to their works. And then
at the end of the thousand years, we
have the execution of the judgment. We
read about this in ex or in Revelation
chapter 20. It talks about the
resurrection of the first resurrection,
the resurrection of the just. And then
it says in verse 5, the rest of the dead
live not again until the thousand years
were finished. And then says this is the
first resurrection. Now we know that
some of the wicked are going to be alive
when Christ returns. Jesus talked in
Matthew chapter 26 and verse 64 about
those who pierced him being alive. He
says there Jesus said unto them, "Thou
hast said, "Nevertheless, I say unto
you, hereafter shall ye see the son of
man sitting on the right hand of power
and coming in the clouds of heaven." In
Revelation 1:7, it says that all the
tribes of the earth will mourn when they
see Christ coming, including those that
pierced him. So there is in Daniel 12
this special resurrection some to
unrighteousness and we're going to see
that there's going to be an agony uh
experienced by those who pierce Christ
in this special resurrection but that is
not the ultimate punishment or judgment
or execution of their sins. They're
going to be resurrected again after the
thousand years and receive that final
punishment. So, we have the first
resurrection and at the second coming of
Christ, which really is when all of the
wicked are are destroyed by the
brightness of his coming and the saints
go to heaven for a thousand years. Then
there's a thousand-year judgment. And
after the thousand-year judgment, when
the books are looked into, and
everyone's sentence is is appropriated.
After that, the resurrection of the
wicked. And in that resurrection of the
wicked, you have the final judgment upon
all of those who have rejected the grace
of God. May we be in that first
resurrection by God's grace and love.
>> Amen. And we all have that opportunity
to be in that first resurrection. Thank
you so much. We're going to go right now
to the contact information here at 3ABN.
If you would like to send in a Bible
question for yourself.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
[music] on those texts that seem
difficult to understand. To have your
questions answered on a future program,
just email them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text [music] your questions
to 6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through a Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
Welcome back. We love these programs
where we just get to open up the word of
God and share with you as our 3ABN
family. Thank you so much, Pastor James
and Pastor Ryan. Just love serving in
ministry with you. Love your heart for
God and knowledge of the word. And let's
have some closing thoughts. Pastor
James, we'll start with you.
>> I want to go back to that question on
Romans chap 11, just looking at verse
15, just to summarize a thought here. It
says, "For if the first fruit be holy,
the lump is also holy. And if the root
be holy, so are the branches." And a lot
of times people think that the first
fruit or the root is talking about
Israel, but it's actually talking about
Jesus. He is the first fruits according
to 1 Corinthians 15:25. Jesus is the
root and the offspring of David.
according to Roman Revelation 5:5. So
when we are in Christ, then we have the
promises that were given to Abraham.
When we are in Christ, then we are God's
chosen people, spiritual Israel. Some
people call that replacement theology. I
would say that if you are putting Israel
in the place of Christ, that is
replacement theology. We need to put
Christ in his rightful place and be his
branches.
>> Amen. Pastor Ryan,
>> you know, I really like the theme of
hope that has run through everything.
And I was kind of asking is that just
happen stance? It's just the questions
that are together. And as I was
thinking, you know, no matter what
subject matter, the theme of hope would
be coming to the surface. I praise the
Lord that he is a God that gives us
hope. Hope in his coming. Hope of
forgiveness, hope of reconciliation. And
of course, when our hope is in Jesus
Christ, it is not an empty hope.
>> Amen. Thank you so much. Thank you for
sharing from your heart and knowledge of
the word. Love serving together in
ministry. and we thank you for being
part of our 3ABN family. Thank you for
sending in your questions and know that
we love you and we pray for you. We will
see you next time.
>> [music]
[music]